our main story tonight concerns shopping
an easy and enjoyable way to forget that
you and everyone you know will one day
die specifically it concerns one of the
most ubiquitous places to go shopping in
this country dollar stores the discount
Outlets where you can get a variety of
goods at sometimes a dollar or less and
then position themselves with upbeat
materials like this whether you're
making a quick fill-in stop or stocking
up for the week Dollar General helps you
save on the things you need and the
unexpected items that make shopping fun
something new for the house a greeting
card or a surprise for someone special
ultimately we love helping our customers
save time and money it's what drives us
that's why more than 125,000 people have
joined our team and we're growing every
day wow they really captured a wide
array of definitely human people in that
ad they've got an old lady a nurse a man
who absolutely does not have kids Molly
ring walls and some idiot about to buy a
bouquet of half inflated balloons today
two companies dominate this particular
Retail Landscape Dollar General and
Dollar Tree which also owns Family
Dollar these two corporations operate
more than 35,000 dollar stores in the US
that is more than all Walmart Starbucks
and McDonald's combined and they have
earnings to match last year Dollar
General made 2.4 billion in profit while
Dollar Tree made 1.6 billion and their
growth has been fueled by targeting
lowincome customers singling out
communities that have been marginalized
economically often rural areas and
neighborhoods of color a former Dollar
General CEO once described their
customer base as being in a permanent
recession and their current CEO summed
up the business like this I would tell
you we do very good in good times and we
do fabulous in in bad times right it's a
store that tends to do better when its
customers are doing worse which isn't
something that really requires use of
the word fabulous fabulous is best used
to describe a quirky hat or the cast of
The Golden Bachelor or the fact that Kim
control made a million dollars to sit in
a car and not talk to Sarah Jessica
Parker that is fabulous but a company
bragging about how it can profit of
financial hardship not so much you might
have heard stories about how dollar
stores impact the communities that they
are in which can where they can be the
only food retailer around in some cases
that may be because they've driven
others out in others it could be because
they've entered a market that's already
a food desert but either way customers
often turn to these stores for their
convenience and low prices although
those prices can be a bit misleading as
this clip from a few years ago
demonstrates a Dollar Tree a two pack of
Irish Spring soap costs a dollar at
Target an eight pack cost
$3.99 but if you look very closely the
bars sold at Dollar Tree they're smaller
so if you do the math Irish Spring by
the ounce is actually more expensive at
Dollar Tre right despite the promise of
value you can end up getting less for
more although I will say in the case of
Irish Spring that's not necessarily a
bad thing I'm just saying I personally
don't want more of something that smells
like a citrus burgot fart and leaves
these money makers ashy as hell but the
fact is if all you can afford for soap
is a dollar right now a dollar store
will sell it to you but look we're not
going to focus on the location or
pricing of dollar stores tonight we're
going to focus on how they are run
because if you've ever set foot in one
you know they can look like a total
disaster I really don't know where
everybody else is getting their Dollar
Trees cuz every single one I've ever
walked into has looked like this oh yes
shopping at the
DG I need staples and they're about 20
ft down that way my God why does my
Dollar Tree look like K look at this
Dollar
Tree like what the yeah what the
is right those look less like
functioning stores and more like
American Ninja Warrior retail Edition
they look like someone picked up a
dollar store shook it and dumped it out
into another dollar store and a quick
shout out to the automated Tik Tok voice
there trying to say the word Kaka she's
doing her absolute best that is all that
we can ask of her that and maybe to say
naughty things like penis oh vagina oh
Charles Manson was lowkey hot in a
character act Griffin kind of exactly
but to an extent that you may not
realize that chaos isn't a one-off
mistake or the fault of those stores
employees it is The Natural end product
of how the companies Behind These stores
choose to operate them and if you think
it can be bad shopping at a dollar store
it is nothing compared to what it's like
working there it's been said that
working at Dollar General may be the
worst retail job in America and if these
stores are this ubiquitous make this
much money and are this terrible to work
for tonight as we get ready for Black
Friday let's talk about dollar stores
and let's start with the fact that one
of the key ways that they squeeze
margins isn't on Tiny soaps it's on
labor costs they often have just two
employees or sometimes even just one
Manning the entire store just watch as
this Dollar Tree customer discovers in
real time that there is only one person
working there only worker here only
worker doing this with no shelves no
nothing look at
this
they she's the only worker
here everything
Guys these people don't even work here
and they're helping her look at this
walls of
boxes all by herself yeah of course the
stores are going to look like that when
there's only one person there to do
everything it's so bad random dudes are
pitching you to help her for free
imagine how monumentally shitty a store
would have to be for you a customer to
walk in and say say oh they need
me it reminds me of that famous Mr
Rogers quote when you walk into a dollar
store that looks like Chernobyl after
the blast look for the helpers you will
always find people who are
helping and incidentally the people
employed by dollar stores are not making
much more than those volunteer helpers
just watch as a former Dollar General
worker points out the disparity between
what the top execs make and what the
rank and file do y'all out there riding
damn expensive car y'all go out eat
crabs and steak and fimon and esaro and
all this meanwhile y'all workers
are eating raymen noodles come on now
y'all making millions think about it I
want everybody to think about it let me
know when did a dollar general worker
make more than 20,000 in a whole year
don't worry I'll wait excellent I've
never heard a harsher insult than simply
listing out Foods you assume someone
else eat
crabs steak filet minan escaro and all
this she's describing a cartoon
rich person and it's devastating I have
no doubt that she she would take one
look at me and go mushy peas figgy
pudding and all that milk and I'd be
wrecked and the thing is she's right
about the numbers there the median
compensated employee for Dollar General
makes around $188,000 a year and a
report two years ago found that
92% of Dollar General's staff was making
less than $15 an hour that is a higher
percentage than every other company they
surveyed on top of that lawsuits and
press reports have repeatedly documented
Dollar General severely restricting the
total hours it allocates in a week to
non-managers and then expecting store
managers who are salaried to cover the
rest without overtime and without enough
people to do everything from running the
register to receiving truck deliveries
to stocking the shelves to keeping
prices updated and cleaning the
bathrooms things can quickly fall apart
just watch as this assistant manager
sends up what is basically an SOS to the
company okay this is a video for help to
anyone inside this company that actually
cares we are overloaded with Freight and
we don't have enough hours in the week
or per people in the week to put them
away we are completely overwhelmed the
back room is like
this I can't even get to the cooler and
I've got a milk delivery outside so
hopefully it all goes out on the sales
floor I don't know again this
video is for anybody in the company that
cares this is Travis Bennett the
assistant manager at store
11132 wow it is not good if your
employees are making Tik toks that look
like hostage videos because that is not
what Tik Tok is for as we all know is
for finding out which anime character
strangers would pork and seeing what
you'd look like positively
snatched but the problem with addressing
that to anybody in the company that
cares is that it sure seems like these
companies ities do not care at all it is
hard to overstate the indifference These
Chains can show to their employees
working conditions and not just in their
stores but in some of their distribution
centers too you may remember us showing
you video of rats inside the Family
Dollar store in White Haven and the
company's distribution center in West
Memphis Arkansas take another look right
now federal inspectors say they have
found more than a thousand rodents
inside the same Distribution Center
oh my goodness okay set aside the
thousands rodents which I know is
already a big ask I just want to take a
second to acknowledge this little diva
look at her not giving two shits about
being fed a pringle other rats would
pounce at the sight of that chip but not
her she's giving it a blank look that
says honey not even at my lowest she has
got standards she has got taste she is
Ratatouille to Absolute food
for that FDA inspection not only
found that more than a thousand dead
rodents had been recovered at that
Distribution Center last year but also
that the company's own records showed
that it collected more than 2,300 RS
there the spring and summer before
demonstrating and I quote a history of
infestation but at that point it's less
an infestation and more a flourishing
community of rats establishing an
internal order building out their
environment probably exploring the Arts
this was both a massive problem for
family and a genuinely inspiring story
of rodent fortitude now the company
wants you to know that they've since
shut down that distribution center and
are thoroughly remodeling it but that's
just one example in a horrifying pattern
for dollar stores Dollar General also
has had to temporarily close multiple
stores and a distribution center for rat
infestations and at one store in
Oklahoma birds nested in the ceiling and
I'm so serious started all over
the merchandise not just that when the
staff told hups in the company they say
that they were ordered not to throw the
soiled products out but to clean them in
some cases by bringing them home to wash
and then return them to the shelves and
when that store's manager asked for help
in removing the nest he said he got the
sense that he was being ignored because
the birds weren't stealing anything and
look there are plenty of reasons to kick
anyone or anything out of a store even
if they aren't stealing anything and
number one on that list is they're
pooping everywhere I don't care if it's
a bird or a toddler the second is
part of the equation they've got to go
now legally I do have to tell you Dollar
General was asked about that bird story
and its response was that it takes
prompt action when stores make
maintenance or repair requests which as
statements go sounds to me a little bit
like uh what's the word kaker that's
right thank you very much and if you're
thinking okay I'm convinced these stor
sound like a terrible place to work I am
not nearly Done Yet some Dollar General
employees have said they are unable to
control the thermostats at stores and
others say that they don't have
functioning heat and cooling systems at
all the heat would cause all the candy
to melt and I don't know if it was
negatory on the medications but I mean I
know they got to be climate controlled
my assistant manager was sitting in
there with ice packs down her pants and
her shirt and a towel cuz we were just
dripping and sweat that's not great an
ice pack down the pants is not how you
imagine a day at work going it is
however how I imagine these two freaks
and when you take all this together
the heat the underst Staffing the boxes
everywhere meaning you can't move around
properly it is pretty clear these places
aren't just unpleasant they're unsafe
Dollar General is on OSHA's severe
violators list racking up more than $25
million in proposed fin since 2017 for
alleged violations spanning dozens of
states and as for Dollar Tree in that
same time frame o identified more than
400 violations in its stores imposing
more than $13 million in fines now I
have to say do Tre recently entered a
settlement with OSHA and claims that
it's implementing substantial safety
policies procedures and training to
safeguard the well-being of our
Associates although you should also know
they had a similar settlement back in
2015 and made similar promises back then
so at best they are a slow learner here
and there is one last indignity for
dollar store employees and that is the
threat of violence dollar stores have
become magnets for crime and killing
with employees at Dollar General saying
they've been stabbed shot held at Point
punched and Pistol whipped on the job
and when a robbery does happen the
response from corporate can be less than
compassionate remember that worker
talking about how the bosses were eating
filet minion here she is talking about
the day her store was robbed I was
robbed at the same Dollar General where
I currently worked I picked up my phone
and called 911 I locked the door I
secured the the customers I followed
protocol called our manager she showed
up I called our district manager like
two or three times she didn't answer but
when my manager called she answered the
first question was is everybody okay the
second thing she
said what are we going to do about
reopening the
store we haven't even been robbed even
dog on 10 to 15 minutes and you already
talking about open it up the store that
is ridiculous an armed robbery is a
traumatic event people need time to
recover from it's not something you can
just ignore like a Spam call or a broken
light bulb or any show on Apple TV did
you know Octavia Spencer sted as a true
crime podcaster on a show called truth
be told for three seasons of course you
didn't it's Apple TV where celebrities
go to
hide while researching this piece Dollar
Store workers repeatedly told us how
they feared for their safety and while
these companies say that they take
security concerns seriously experts have
said that the level of violence may be
down to how these stores are set up and
organized having so few people working
there with no security guard typically
present makes them an incredibly
enticing Target in Texas a Dollar
General employee who had a coworker Die
In Her Arms claimed in a lawsuit that
her store had no lights at the back of
the building and cash registers that
didn't have Panic buttons and that the
sign announcing a remotely monitored
security system was a sham and at that
point they might as well have just put
up one of those inflatable floppy men
holding a plunder me babe son
at almost every turn dollar stores seem
to treat their workers with either
stunning indifference or outright
contempt and some are getting so fed up
they are walking out leading to stories
like this we saw dozens of people trying
to go inside Family Dollar this
afternoon only to find the doors locked
and no one inside Garfield resident
Dodie burn went to Family Dollar on pen
Avenue yesterday only to find this sign
saying staff quit y'all be easy on the
door yeah and that is not at all
uncommon at another Family Dollar in
Nebraska staff left this sign on the
door we all quit sorry for the
inconvenience and at the Dollar General
in Maine workers left a series of signs
reading closed indefinitely because
Dollar General doesn't pay a living wage
or treat their employees with respect
and capitalism will destroy this country
if you don't pay people enough to live
their lives why should they slave away
for you all of which is punctuated
perfectly by the excited now hiring sign
which really has it's work cut out for
it and while those workers are
justifiably walking out others are
choosing to fight back over the past few
years groups like stepup Louisiana and
the Union of Southern service workers
have staged strikes and protests against
Dollar General but the company has
pushed back hard in all the usual union
busting ways in Connecticut when workers
tried to organize Dollar General
violated federal law by firing a
pro-union worker illegally surveilling
and interrogating employees and
threatening to close the store they also
make all new employees watch a video
where they talk the very idea of
joining a union which one worker filmed
and posted online we don't believe that
our employees need a third party or
Union to come between us and Them our
employees don't need a union to have
their voices heard here at Dollar
General I'm sorry your employees are
able to get their voices heard are you
sure about that cuz it seems like the
guy pleading for aid from Tik Tok
strangers might really beg to differ on
that point so what is there to do well
since 2019 at least 75 communities many
of them lower income have actually
blocked proposals to build new dollar
stores but the truth is most of these
stores are unlikely to go anywhere
remember in many areas they're the only
retailer around so much more attention
needs to be paid to what workers have
been saying and for years now Dollar
Store workers at stepup Louisiana have
developed a list of what they are asking
for from these companies from things
like having safe Staffing level lels to
creating safe store infrastructure to
giving workers a right to heal after
violent incidents none of which is
really asking much and until such time
as these companies actually do these
things they should at the very least
have to be much more transparent when it
comes to the retail and workplace
experience that they're actually
providing hi there here at Dollar bucket
whether you're making a quick fill-in
stop or stocking up for the week we've
got everything you need like this roll
of toilet paper or an adorable bar of
Irish Spring dollar bucket helps you
save on the things you need but also on
the special treats that make life a
little more well fun like this flaccid
balloon or this bag of Skittle you mean
Skittles nope a dollar bucket whatever
you need we've got it somewhere uh-oh
and oh always at the right price towels
a dollar batteries a dollar this rat a
dollar Gatorade Frost Arctic Blitz a
dollar this other rat a dollar that last
rat was pregnant so that's a
twofer we love helping our customers
save time and money that's why over
125,000 people have joined our team and
we're growing every day hey I don't work
here I'm just trying to get the milk
refrigerated before it goes bad this
place is well you better hurry
we've got another shipment coming
[Applause]
in dollar buckets a proud provider of
jobs in our communities take Brenda here
she's our longest serving employee hey
Brenda how long have you been with us
I've been here for 3 weeks okay and it's
a nightmare and I got ice packs in
places only God and my husband should
say okay I've been in an adult
diaper cuz I can't go to the bathroom
and we've been robbed three times since
lunch and we still open Brenda if we
closed every time we got robbed this
store would never be open and you would
not have a job young lady I've been here
I'm so long I I don't know what day it
is I keep hearing voices screaming
Brenda help Brenda can you help me is a
is that the voice okay this is a video
for help to anyone inside this company
that actually cares I can't leave the
stock room there are too many boxes in
the way and also the birds won't let me
leave oh God br oh God is he okay what's
happening to Travis doesn't
matter what you don't understand is that
your lives are insignificant your pain
is our fuel the more you suffer the
better we do this company was built on
pain sweat tears and the tiniest little
bars of doll soap you've ever seen in
your worthless godamn lives
number one go yourself I know ain't
happen in a long time cuz that suit is
tight oh it happens oh it did wa this
morning Brenda really that's then you're
going to have to pay a dollar for that
I'll pay nothing cuz I quit can you read
that I can it says I quit I quit bye-bye
byebye byebye bye-bye
[Applause]
good
hey you want a job we can pay you in rat
babies how
many dollar bucket giving everyone less
while we get
[Music]
more